Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin Herr Karaj.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Städtebund.
Wir werden gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Und bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Ja, das ist klar.
Jetzt darf ich Ihren Namen erfahren.
Ich heiße Birgit Meisen.
Könnten Sie Ihren Namen bestehlen?
Ja, der Vorname ist B-I-R-G-I-T.
Birgit.
Und der Familienname ist Meisen M-E-I-S-E-N.
Wieder plural von den kleinen Bundenvögeln.
Meisen.
Okay, danke schön.
Und jetzt möchte ich ganz schnell allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15.08.65.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin jetzt nur noch 54,5 kg.
54,5.
Ja, Frau Meisen, was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, ich muss vielleicht ein ganz klein bisschen ausholen.
Also ich habe sehr heftige Schmerzen in der linken Leiste
und habe auch das Gefühl, dass ich nicht so gut Luft bekomme.
Und zwar ist es eigentlich seit gestern schon
und die Schmerzen, die strahlen in den Rücken und in das linke Wein.
Aber sie brauchen tatsächlich noch eine Information davor.
Denn ich hatte vor vier Wochen eine Operation.
Und zwar ist ein Melanom entfernt worden und die Lymphknoten sind entfernt.
Und das war halt ein linken Wein.
Und vor zwei Wochen haben die mit der Chemotherapie angefangen.
Und da geht es mir natürlich insgesamt nicht so gut.
Wann war die Chemotherapie?
Seit zwei Wochen.
Und das macht mich natürlich auch jetzt so ziemlich kao.
Seitdem geht es mir nicht gut.
Ich mir ist schlecht und ich fühle mich schlapp.
Und ja, ich merke schon, dass das unangenehm ist.
Okay. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzskala von eins bis zehn.
Eins ist sehr stark.
Ja, also ich kann das schon noch aushalten.
Also ich würde sagen, bei fünf sind die.
Okay.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, wo die Schmerzen genau sind?
Also überwiegend würde ich sagen in der linken Leiste.
Und die strahlen eben aus in das ganze linke Bein rein.
Und die strahlen auch so hoch in den Rücken.
Okay.
Ja, sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gegen sie wieder weg?
Ja, also sie sind mal stärker und mal weniger stark.
Und.
Was ich gemerkt habe, wenn ich mich ein bisschen bewege,
dann wird es ein bisschen besser.
Hatten Sie so endlich ein beschwerden für Sie schon einmal?
Nein, das so was kenne ich gar nicht.
Deswegen bin ich auch gleich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Wenn ich richtig verstehe,
haben Sie eine Melanom in Linkenbein?
Genau.
Und habe vor zwei Wochen eine Chemotrepidiat.
Ja, und vor vier Wochen halt die OP, ne?
Ja, gibt es Faktoren, die die Schmerzen lindern oder verstanden?
Ja, was ich eben schon dachte, wenn ich mich ein bisschen bewege,
habe ich das Gefühl, dass es besser wird.
Ja, und dass ich dann auch wieder besser Luft kriege.
Und haben Sie Luftnot hatten?
Ja, ja, ja.
Könnten Sie flachlegen, ohne Luftnot zu bekommen?
Nee, das geht nicht gut.
Aber das ist eigentlich erst seit gestern.
Haben Sie Gusten, Schraumeisten, meiden?
Nee, so richtig Gusten habe ich nicht, nee.
Haben Sie Herzschlasen oder Herzgruppen bemerkt?
Na ja, jetzt, weil mir so übel ist, habe ich manchmal so das Gefühl,
dass ich Herzklopfen habe.
Aber ich glaube, das ja, also so ausgeprägt eigentlich nicht.
Wenn ich richtig verstehe, haben Sie übel oder?
Bitte, was habe ich?
Haben Sie übel?
Mir ist übel, ja, also ich habe Übelkeit, ja.
Ja, das kommt von der Chemo, denke ich, ne?
Weil das eben angefangen hat, als ich mit der Chemo begonnen habe.
Und Gusten, Sie Erbrechen?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Haben Sie Jeschulene Bein oder Physiö bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Schraumeisten, haben Sie Fieberg im Moment?
Nee, also Fieberg, fühle ich mich nicht.
Ich habe aber auch ehrlich gesagt nicht gemessen.
Aber also Fieberg oder so fühle ich mich nicht.
Haben Sie Schütterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nee, das habe ich nicht.
Ich habe schlecht geschlafen.
Aber wegen der Schmerzen, denke ich mal.
Ja, insgesamt aber, also ich habe es,
ich habe es keine Nachschweiß gehabt, nee.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich verändert?
Ja, doch, ich habe in acht Wochen ordentlich abgenommen.
Ich habe vier Kilo abgenommen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Ja, sagt ich ja gerade, dass ich zur Zeit nicht gut schlafe.
Wie viele Kisten wenden Sie?
Ja, jetzt habe ich mir so ein zweites drunter gemacht, ja.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stücken?
Nee, ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Durchschwein oder Obstuppe?
Nee, mein Stücken ist ganz normal.
Wie ist es, aber ihr repetitiv?
Ja, zur Zeit ist es nicht so gut.
Seit ich mit der Chemo da angefangen habe und heute ja nun schon gar nicht mit den Schmerzen jetzt.
Aber normalerweise habe ich eigentlich immer ganz gut gegessen.
Okay, normalerweise haben Sie noch weitere Beschwärzen oder Symptome gemacht?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, habe ich vielleicht noch nicht erzählt,
dass ich jetzt im Rahmen der Chemo habe ich das auch gemerkt,
dass ich häufiger mal Nasenbluten hatte.
Wie oft diese Beschwärzen?
Ja, jetzt schon ein paar Mal, ich würde sagen, so jeden zweiten Tag.
Das ist nie lange, aber halt so, dass es lästig ist.
Haben Sie Ihre Gutglück gemessen?
Nee, habe ich nicht gemessen.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt würde ich Ihnen einige Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte.
Okay?
Beide Sie an Fronschenerkrankungen?
Na ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich kann das nur von dieser Melanomerkrankung erzählen,
aber was anderes sonst bin ich eigentlich immer gesund gewesen, ja.
Verboten Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich mir vor zehn Jahren mal die linken Unterarm gebrochen
und das ist operativ versorgt worden.
Operativ versorgt?
Ja.
Und Frau Meisen, nehmen Sie Regen- oder genigenzlich Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme Ibuprofen, dreimal eine.
Und bei Bedarf, wenn ich unruhig bin oder so jetzt wegen dieser Krebserkrankung,
dann nehme ich Halloperidol.
Da habe ich Tropfen.
Tropfen?
Wie oft?
Ja, die nehme ich nur, wenn ich merke, dass es mir nicht gut geht.
Okay.
Wie ist die Dosierung für Ibuprofen?
Ja, das ist Ibuprofen 400.
Und da nehme ich morgens, mittags und abends.
Okay.
Frau Meisen, haben Sie Allergien?
Nee, ich bin nicht, das ist mir nichts bekannt.
Nein, ich habe keine Allergien.
Oder Unfärktlichkeiten?
Nee, bisher war immer alles gut.
Deswegen bin ich ja so genervt, dass es ja so schlecht ist, ja.
Okay.
Und Frau Meisen, wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Ich bin komplett geimpft.
Komplett.
Und sind Sie gegen Abteil COVID-19 geimpft?
Ja.
Okay.
Und Frau Meisen, schalten Sie sich eine?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Gut, sehr schön.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich trinke ich mal gelass Wein, wenn sie es anbietet mit Freunden oder wenn man ein gutes Essen hat, aber sehr selten eigentlich.
Okay.
Und ich muss diese Frage auch stellen, eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, also wenn Sie jetzt das Halloperidol nicht als Droge ansehen, nehme ich keine Drogen.
Nein.
Und?
Ich habe in Ihrer Familie schwere oder chronische Erkrankungen.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Also mein Vater hatte Logenkrebs und er ist mit 76 daran gestorben.
Und meine Mutter hatte einen Schmarrkantal.
Wie alt war er?
Bitte?
76 Jahre alt geworden.
Ich storben.
Und er ist verstorben, ja, genau.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, meine Mutter hatte mit nicht mal 70 einen Schlaganfall und die hat es wirklich eigentlich doll erwischt.
Die hat richtig eine Halbseitenlehmung zurückbehalten und ist auch rollstuhlschlichtig.
Also die ist wirklich höchstbedürftig jetzt.
Und haben Sie geistig?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die hat mal was erzählt, dass sie so Darmen Probleme hat.
Die hat irgendwie Polypen im Darmen und ist da regelmäßig in Kontrolle.
Okay.
Und, was ist Ihr Beruf für ein Meister?
Ja, ich arbeite als Angestellte im Einwohner-Meldeamt und habe da also ein Büro-Top.
Und ihr seid Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter habe ich.
Sind Sie gesund?
Meine Tochter, ja, die ist mehr als gesund.
Das macht mir gerade ein bisschen Sorgen.
Die ist erst 19 Jahre und ja, die ist schwanger jetzt.
Und da mache ich mir natürlich ein bisschen Sorgen drum, was aus ihr wird.
Das kann sehr sein.
Und legen Sie mit Ihrem Mann zusammen?
Ja, ja. Und die Tochter wohnt auch noch bei uns.
Klar, Meisen.
Sind Sie regelmäßig beim Genokologen?
Ja, klar.
Haben Sie Probleme bei dem wunderschönen Gehütte?
Ja, ich habe das auch nicht.
Noch mal bitte.
Aber Sie haben Probleme bei der monatlichen Blüten?
Ja, die ist vorbei.
Ich bin in der Menopause schon.
Klar, Meisen.
Jetzt habe ich das aufnahmigespräch so weit nicht schlossen.
Sie haben so viel gefragt.
Ich glaube, ich habe Ihnen wirklich alles erzählt,
das zu sagen, gibt es zu meiner Situation.
Für mich ist jetzt nur noch die Frage, wie können Sie mir helfen?
Was ist denn wahrscheinlich der Hintergrund für meine Schmerzen?
Ja, ich verstehe, aber es ist so früh eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Bitte beruhigen Sie sich.
Ich möchte Ihnen kurz erklären, wie wir weiter vorgehen wollen.
Das ist gut, ja.
Wenn Sie nicht verstanden sind, werde ich Sie für völlig unterzukommen
und Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Dann dürft Sie aufnehmen und durchführen.
Was wollen Sie räumen?
Ich möchte Sie mit der Radiografie eine Stade, eine wild geblende Verfallung.
Das Bein?
Brustblendgen.
Mit der Erdebnisbespräche, ich bespräche Ihre Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann werde ich Sie mit dem Laufenden halten.
Ja, gut, das ist vollumficher.
Gut, hat es noch jemanden zu fragen?
Guten Abend.
Ich habe noch mal Fragen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine gerötet und warm sind?
Nein, hat sie nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass Sie krampfartig sind und dass Sie zunehmen.
Ich tippe mal, dass Sie eher nicht stechend sind, sondern eher dumpf, würde ich sagen.
Aber ich bin ja nicht wirklich in der Haut von den Patienten.
Wie viele Stoffen können Sie steigen, bevor Sie Luftnot haben oder stehen bleiben?
Ich würde nach einer Treppe fängt es schon an zu pusten.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Meysen, ist Ihre Wunsch gut gehalten?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
So weit ich das gesehen habe, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Nasenblutung haben.
Wie lange dauert eine Blutung?
Meistens nicht lange.
Ich habe nur kurz und mache keinen Lappen in den Nacken.
Dann ist das nach 20 Minuten wieder weg.
Haben Sie noch andere Blutungen, wie z.B. Sahnefleisch?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Danke.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, besonders bei Ihren Augen?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Haben Sie Schwindelik?
Schwindelik ist mir tatsächlich nicht.
Mir ist nur schlecht von der Chemotherapie.
Aber Schwindelik ist mir nicht.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie die Schlafstörung und die Verlust haben.
Ich habe nicht die Konzentration schwerer, Taubhausgefühl.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht beschrieben.
Nein, linke Bein-Taubhausgefühl.
Das linke Bein tut nur weh.
Taub ist das leider nicht.
Ich habe die Schmutzung am Gehen.
Im Ordentlich kann ich schlecht laufen.
Wie viele Meter laufen Sie maximal?
Es wird besser, wenn ich mich bewege.
Ich vermeide das Gehen, weil das Bein wehtut.
Ich denke, ich laufe gerade im Haus.
Das, was ich vom Parkplatz zum Krankenhaus bin,
bin ich gelaufen oder zur Praxis.
Aber ich laufe nicht viel im Augenblick wegen der akuten Schmerzen.
Wie viele Tage mussten Sie nach der Operation im Bett liegen?
Ich habe keine Angabe dazu.
Aber die waren nicht lange.
Ein Tag schon, zwei Tage.
Dann ist sie wieder auf den Beinen gewesen.
Ich denke, gegen die Schmerzen von den Beinen.
Was verbessert das?
Normalerweise hilft mir das schon.
Jetzt ist es nicht deutlich besser geworden.
Nach der Chemotherapie geschrieben.
5 Tropfen bei Bedarf.
Was ist die Verbesserung der Bewerber?
Ich habe Angst, dass ich nicht schlafen kann.
Eigentlich gegen die Überkeit.
Ich habe gedacht, dass ich als geriatrisches Verkauf habe.
Aber ich mache es gegen Überkeit.
Dann nehme ich das, wenn mir schlecht ist.
Nein, nein.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Wie viele Tage oder Monate wurde die Diagnose vor der OP gestellt?
Das war nicht lange vorher.
Sie haben relativ schnell dann operiert.
Warum kommen Sie in unser Krankenhaus?
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Sie haben eine Hautveränderung bemerkt.
Ich habe nicht genau auf die Wunde geguckt.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Ich möchte Ihnen über eine Patientin berichten.
Die Patientin heißt Bergitt Meissen.
Sie hat 75 cm groß und 74,5 kg schwer.
Sie hat 54,5 kg schwer.
Sie stellte sich bei uns wegen stärker krampfartiger Schmerzen im leisten Bereich.
Sie stellte sich bei der Bewegung besser.
Sie stellte sich bei uns wegen stärker krampfartiger Schmerzen im Leisten Bereich.
Diese Abgrund der Analyse gehe ich von Lungenetastase und Leistenaccess auf.
Was hätten wir differentialdiagnostisch für eine Option?
Kann das Ganze auch eine Nebenwirkung von der Chemo sein?
Ja, es kann sein.
Sie stellte sich bei uns wegen stärker krampfartiger Schmerzen im Leisten Bereich.
Erstmal müssen wir körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, worauf achten Sie da besonders?
Ich habe die Schmerz gegen die Kontrolle gebetet.
Ich habe es in der anderen Seite geblieben.
Und...
Was ist mit dem Labo?
Labo ist ein sehr guter Labo.
Wir haben jetzt einen Punkt, der Paramedicis überführen.
Der AP und Blutzenkingsrichtigkeits und Lykosikos.
Für die Luftnot vielleicht noch?
Blut spielt.
Wegen der Luftnot, was könnten wir vielleicht da noch gucken?
Der Dimens.
Genau, ob die eine Modi hat, wirklicherweise.
Als sind die Parameter können wir auch.
Als sind die Parameter.
Ja, da hat er schon gedacht, ne?
Der AP, hat er schon gesagt und Unsenkung, ne?
Gut.
Ja, dann, was machen Sie an Apparativeruntersuchung?
Erst mal können wir unter der Suchung.
Wo genau?
Im linken Unterbaubereich und leichten Bereich.
Sehr gut, genau.
Dann können wir Torax-Röntgen fällen lassen.
Ja, mit welcher Fragestellung?
Zwei Ebenen.
Ja, und welche Fragestellung?
Was wollen wir?
Wir haben eine Verdacht auf krimulare emboli,
oder eine jungen Karcinom oder jungen Metastas.
Ganz genau.
Super, genau, das waren die Fragen.
Gut, ja, was machen wir denn therapeutisch mit dieser Patientin?
Wenn sich das bestätigt, dass die, also, ja, dass die,
dass die filialisiert ist?
Wenn die Diagnose eine Absilie ist,
dann müssen wir erstmal eine Therapie mit Antipyretik einleiten.
Aber wenn eine jungen Metastas ist,
dann müssen wir eine Konzil-Konzil,
auf alle Fälle ein unklinisches Konzil, ja, klar.
Aber worauf wird das rauslaufen?
Wir haben ja jetzt auch schon die Idee,
was werden denn die Unkologen mit der Patientin machen?
Wären die die stationelle Aufnehmen?
Erstmal stationelle Aufnehmen und Analgesie einleiten.
Bitte? Analgesie?
Das sieht sie als erstes?
Analgesie zum Beispiel.
Ja, da sind die hier tatsächlich vorsichtig und sagen,
solange sie keine Diagnose haben,
wollen sie keine Analgesie machen,
was sich unnetsch findet.
Ja, nach der Diagnose.
Warum muss sie im Einzelzimmer bleiben, Dr. Gündis?
Warum muss sie im Einzelzimmer sein?
Ich denke, die Patientin hat eine Verdachtdiagnose,
eine Diagnose, eine Hematone,
weil nach der Chemotherapie
anscheinend,
wir oft eine eine Trombopenie,
diese Patientin fällt Fieber
und leistet
keine Ververbung.
Und die Patientin
sagt, sie hat eine Müdigkeit.
Und wir haben eine Erbrechung.
Und Luftnot,
das ist eine Beschwerde.
Luftnot ist, ich denke, eine Anime
und linken Bein Melsen,
eine Hematone.
Das wäre ihre Differenzialdiagnose.
Aber das erklärt ja für mich nicht das Einzelzimmer,
ehrlich gesagt.
M-L ist auch Einzündung.
Die Patientin ist im Münchwar.
Ja, deswegen.
Logisch, ja.
Aber ab sehr erst mal eine Fieber.
Hätten Sie Fieber, genau.
Wahrscheinlich keinen Abszess.
Aber eine Hematone ist wahrscheinlich.
Ich würde sagen,
dass es bei Absäen sind,
die eine Kapsel der Anzahl der Patienten
nicht mehr.
Das ist aufspannend, dass das praktisch noch nicht aufgeworfen ist.
Ja, gut.
Aber Absäen
hat nicht angefangen.
Aber die Patientin sagte,
dass die Hematone nicht mehr aufgeworfen ist.
Natürlich würde ein bisschen zu dem Hematom
das Nasenbluten passen.
Dass die irgendwie ein Verwendungsproblem hat.
Ja.
Aber wir sind jetzt natürlich schon sehr spekulativ unterwegs.
Aber natürlich schon sehr spekulativ unterwegs.
Aber das passt natürlich zusammen.
Ja, das passt natürlich zusammen.
Erwärter Sie Hematone
beim Neutropänen
im Pansytopen?
Weil ich habe gelesen, immer
Zahnflaschenblutung,
Epistaxis.
Ja, die richtige Diagnose ist Pansytopen.
Das ist richtig. Aber gibt es keine Erklärung
für die Schmerzen im Leistenbereich?
Ich habe gedacht auch Hematone.
Aber ich kann nicht gelesen,
diese Informationen.
Haben Sie noch Informationen?
Zowed-Adafraa-Gündes.
Ich denke 7 hatt eignen,
der Verdaft Diagnose, ABAMUS-MAN
argumentzag.
Ich habe schon gelesen im Hierarchie Fisstinall-Hierogie,
eine Zweive-Wohne-Lymph-Adenecktomie
düşgefürt geworden.
Und danach komplikationen
nach Komplikationen bei dieser Patientin oft eine Hematom und Absäß, aber nicht Absäß,
Entzündung. Ja, okay, dann ja. Also es wäre denkbar, dass der als Komplikation
praktisch jetzt das Hematom in der Leiste hat. Eine andere alternative wäre eine Entzündung
der Wunde. Das muss man natürlich bei der körperlichen Untersuchung angucken,
logisch und es passt allerdings zur Entzündung nicht so wirklich dazu, dass sie noch kein Fieber hat.
Ja, und wenn sie aber, hat sie es einfach nur noch nicht gemerkt, dass sie Fieber hat,
muss man vielleicht dann auch nochmal Körpertemperatur nachmessen. Gut, ja.
Ich habe noch eine Frage. Ja, die Patientin hat gesagt, ja, ich habe eine Tochter und sie ist
schwanger. Ja, wie würdest du in dieser Situation als empathisch reagieren? Das ist immer schwierig
für mich, weil es eine kulturelle. Ja, also das würde ich tatsächlich davon anfänglich machen,
wie sie das erzählt. Ich glaube, sie hat das jetzt tatsächlich so auch erzählt, dass sie
sagt, ja, die wohnt auch bei mir zu Hause. Das ist natürlich nicht so ganz in meinem Sinne,
dass die jetzt mit noch ein Zehnt schwanger ist. Und sicherlich wäre das jetzt nicht richtig zu
sagen, oh, herzlichen Glückwunsch, sie werden Oma. Das wäre vielleicht nicht so ganz der super
richtige, die richtige Reaktion da drauf. Oder vielleicht würde man sagen, ja, da machen sie
sich bestimmt Sorgen, was aus ihrer Tochter wird und wie sie damit der Situation zu Recht
kommt oder sowas könnte man sagen. Und das hat sie ja eigentlich auch so angedeutet, dass sie damit
ein bisschen Stress hat jetzt und das könnte man sicherlich so ohne irgendjemand jetzt zu nahe
zu treten formulieren, dass man sagt, oh ja, mit der Situation müssen sie sie jetzt als Familie
erst mal zurecht kommen oder so. Kannst du damit etwas anfangen, Lisa? Ja, ja. Das ist besser.
Patient hat gesagt mehr als gesund. Genau, stimmt. Ja, stimmt, das habe ich gesagt. Ja,
ja, also die Mutter ist nicht begeistert, dass die Tochter mit einer Ausheilung jetzt
ein Kind ankommt. Das ist schon ein Kennenweier. Gut, zumal sie eben selber nicht gesund ist. Ja,
wenn man weiß, man ist knallgesund und kann selber noch ein Kind großziehen, sagt man vielleicht ja,
ist egal, ne? Nehm ich mit. Gut. Ja, tatsächlich waren hier noch zusätzliche Fragen angegeben.
Und die sind aber zum Teil auch jetzt aus dem Klänen umgekommen. Und zwar einmal die wichtige
Frage natürlich haben sie Arztbriefe vorbefundet dabei, haben sie ein Schema von der Chemotherapie
dabei. Da hat sie ja gesagt, habe ich jetzt nicht hier, aber mein Mann hat die Befunde im Auto,
ne? Aber das ist natürlich eine wichtige Information. Dann ja, die Frage sind die
ich jetzt nicht so relevant, ob man im Ausland war, finde ich in dem Zusammenhang eigentlich Wumpe.
Ja. Haben die aber hier erwähnt, ne? Dann sicherlich legitim nochmal die Nachfrage,
wo genau sind die Lymphknurren entfernt worden? Aber eigentlich ja logisch, wo sollen die entfernt
werden, wenn nicht in der Leiste, aber Nachfragen kann man ja mal. Und tatsächlich hat ja auch
jemand aus dem Plenum schon gefragt, wann das Melanom tatsächlich entdeckt worden ist.
Ne? Und da habe ich ja dann selber angegeben, dass das schnell dann, dass die schnell operiert
haben, nachdem sie es gefunden haben. Ich glaube, das macht man auch tatsächlich immer noch.
Eine Melanom ist immer noch glaube ich so bekannt als als bösartig, dass man da relativ zügig
operiert, oder? Ja. Richtig, ne? Ja. Ja. Und soweit im zweiten Punkt ist,
die Patienten gefragt, die Patienten fragt immer, meine Vater ist wegen Karstenon gestorben und
werde ich aussterben. Okay. Ja, das habe ich tatsächlich jetzt hier nicht als Befund,
als Fragevorschlag, aber ist natürlich schon so eine Sache, wenn da eine Karstenomeerkrankung
in der Familie ist, dass jemand dann sagt, wow, ne, geht das jetzt so weiter? Ja. Aber
glaube, diese Patientin hier sagt tatsächlich, das Bein ist weit weg so ungefähr, ne? Warum tut
mir das jetzt weh? Und hat vielleicht noch nicht so den, den Fokus darauf, wie gefährlich das sein
kann. Ja. Gut, dann sind tatsächlich noch Prüferfragen gekommen. Echt erstaunlich zu dem Thema
halbseitige Lemo. Dann sind wir den Fachbegriff.
Oder Hemiplegie, ne? Genau. Und also danach haben die hier in der Prüfung gefragt,
sie machen ja oft so abseitige Fragen, dass sie praktisch ganz weg vom Fall
dann irgendein Stichwort aufnehmen und sagen, sie hat etwas von der, von der Mutter erzählt,
was ist Tätrapligie zum Beispiel und was ist, wie nennen wir, eine Querschnittslehmung, ja? Gut,
dann haben die tatsächlich auch noch zum Malignemelanomen gefragt und haben gefragt,
ist Ibuprofen für die Schmerztherapie ausreichend? Die Therapie
richtet nach Schwedegrad der Patientin. Ja, wenn die mit den Ibupis her ausgekommen ist, ist okay,
aber man könnte auch praktisch noch höher gehen, ne? Und auf ein anderes Medikament,
praktisch. Und dann ist noch eine Extrafahe gewesen,
wohin typischerweise das Malignemelanomen metastasiert?
Meistens zu Lungen, Gehirn und Knochen. Ja, genau. Und dann haben die
noch nach Risikofaktoren für Malignemelanomen gefragt.
Sommen, nicht drinnenstrahlen. Und genetische Keranlankung.
Genau, sehr gut. Und dann haben die noch was gesagt von einer ABCDI Regel zur Beurteilung
von Muttermalen oder Nevi. Haben sie das schon mal gehört? Ja,
einmal aber ich kann daran nicht erinnern. Ja.
Sehr gut. Deshalb kann man es nicht erklären. Ja, also das sind die Dinge,
die man zur Beurteilung von Nevi, wie weit die gefährdet sind für Malignemelanomen.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, in guter Gemeinschaftsarbeit haben wir tatsächlich auch diese ganz speziellen
Fragen nochmal sehr schön geklärt. Natürlich sehr schön, wenn wir eine Spezialistin an Bord haben.
Was haben Sie für eine Sacharztausbildung? Ich bin auch genannt.
Ja, das ist natürlich abseitig dann jetzt ein bisschen. Ja, sorry.
Melanom aba, melanom könn bir aba im Aogen, Zainia.
Achso gibt es auch, ja stimmt ja. Gut, aber ich fand tatsächlich sehr gut,
die komplette Anamnese, das Gespräch mit der Patientin war komplett und war auch sehr strukturiert.
Tatsächlich bei der Vorstellung, die war ein bisschen stockend von der Sprache her,
ist zwar alles gekommen, aber war noch nicht so, also ich sage mal nicht so elegant und so
flüssig wie die Fragen beim Anamnese-Gespräch. Da gab es so sprachlich gar keine Unsicherheiten.
Und bei der Erklärung dann oder bei der Schilderung desfalls war es ein ganz bisschen holperiger
oder so, aber ich denke mal, damit kann man sicherlich sehr gut in Sachsen eine Prüfung bestehen.